vous venez de le voir avec ce
documentaire signé par Chantal lasba le
24 octobre
1963 le journaliste français jeandiiel
rencontre John philgald Kennedy à la
Maison Blanche un mois plus tard à Cuba
il s'entretient longuement avec Fidel
Castro le jour même de l'assassinat de
GfK qu'il vit alors en direct au côté du
leader cubain alors Castro Kennedy un
rendez-vous manqué point d'interrogation
et bien nous allons en débattre
maintenant après ce film en compagnie de
nos deux invités présents aujourd'hui
sur ce plateau de débadoc en commençant
par vous Serge Raffi euh bienvenue vous
êtes éditorialiste au point et écrivain
vous avez auparavant longtemps officier
au Nouvel Observateur hebdomadaire qu' a
longtemps dirigé Jeandel que vous avez
par ailleurs bien connu et vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres de Castro
l'infidèle un Nou ouvrage publié chez
Fayard puis réédité je crois en poche
hein donc chacun peut encore se se
procurer votre ouvrage Serge Raffier
puis en face de vous André caspi
bienvenue vous êtes historien
spécialiste des États-Unis qui n'a pas
lu André caspi lorsqu'il était question
de l'histoire américaine c'est en
réalisé la question et c'est une manière
de souligner le plaisir que nous avons à
vous recevoir de nouveau dans cette
émission débadoc et puis votre dernier
livre s'intitule lui la nation armée les
armes au cœur de la culture américain
un ouvrage publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire Serge Raffi un mot pour
commencer sur jeandiiel il est au cœur
de cette histoire dans la grande
histoire mais c'est un véritable scoop
qu'il a réussi à réaliser en ce mois et
en cette année
1963 vous avez j'imagine eu l'occasion
d'en reparler avec lui de cette fameux
épisode de ce fameux scoup qu'en
disait-il quelques temps après vous en
parlez d'ailleurs dans votre livre il
était il était très surpris de de la de
la proposition de de de Kennedy parce
que c'était quand même très rare qu'un
président des États-Unis propose à un
journaliste aussi célèbre futile d'aller
négocier quelque part une une une une
une nouvelle position des États-Unis par
rapport à à au au régime cubain donc il
a dans un premier temps été très surpris
évidemment il ne pouvait pas refuser un
scoop pareil s'en était un bien sûr mais
il était aussi très conscient de la de
comment dirais-je de la rou lardise de
fidèle Castro de cette capacité à
retourner les journalistes à les séduire
à savoir aller dans dans leur sens dans
le sens de leur poil et cetera donc il
il a il a compris aussi qu'il était dans
un moment historique ce moment
historique c'est justement ce moment où
Kennedy comprend ou décide avec un
certain nombre de ses collaborateurs
qu'on peut pas continu continuer à
diaboliser le régime cubain et qu'il va
bien falloir à un moment donné trouver
une manière de faire la paix ou du moins
une paix à peu près armée même si elle
est un peu armée et a beaucoup de de de
suspicions mais quand même une manière
de dire on va trouver une nouvelle
manière de vivre ensemble et puis euh il
le raconte hein évidemment cet épisode
dans dans ce livre he qu'on le voit lire
he de sa propre voix qui s'intitule le
temps qui reste hein c'était son
deuxième livre he c'était une
autobiographie professionnelle qu'il
avait publié en 64 hein je crois premier
extrait du documentaire parce que
commençons par le commencement si vous
en êtes
l' des cochons éche cuisant du côté
américain regardons cet extrait du je
pense que Keny hérité d'une politique
très
agressiveistration dans cette continué
qu' a soutenu jusqu'au bout le régime de
la dictature de
btista
et je pense aussi qu'il ne pouvait pas
imaginer la possibilité d'une
entente d'une relation plus ou moins
civilisée entre les deux
pays donc voilà l'analyse de cet
historien cubain à propos de cette
fameuse opération de la baie des Cochons
le 17 avril 61 où 1400 anticastrist
formé par la CIA tente un débarquement
sur les côtes cubaines John fieldgald
Kennedy encore sous l'influence de
l'administration isenover au moment de
de prendre la décision de de donner son
feu ver pour cette opération de l'AB
baie des Cochons bah il faut bien se
représenter que John Kennedy est
président depuis 3 mois et au paravant
il ne s'est pas spécialement occupé de
la situation à Cuba ça c'est le premier
point mais le deuxième point qu'il faut
souligner c'est que pour les Américains
le mot américain déjà c'est un mot qui a
un sens ça signifie au fond que pour les
États-Unis tout le reste du continent
américain fait partie de la zone
d'influence des États-Unis ils sont eux
les Américains et tous les autres États
sont formés par des
latinoaméricains autrement dit il est
tout à fait naturel pour les États-Unis
de penser que Cuba c'est un domaine
réservé aux Américains c'est-à-dire aux
Américains des États-Unis et que là on
peut investir de l'argent on peut y
mettre éventuellement des représentants
de la mafia qui sont très présents à
Cuba et puis n'oubliez pas qu'il y a
aussi une base américaine à Cuba qui est
Guantanamo elle existe toujours toujours
elle existe toujours ça veut donc dire
que au fond à 150 km des côtes de
Floride Cuba c'est un peu une extension
des États-Unis et si Cuba dévie du côté
des communistes du côté de l'Union
soviétique car on est en pleine guerre
froide ou bah il est évident que le rôle
des États-Unis la mission des États-Unis
c'est d'intervenir c'est d'empêcher en
somme que cette zone d'influence cesse
d'être entre les mains des Américains
pour passer entre les mains des
Soviétiques autrement dit on est là dans
un aspect de la guerre froide et comme
John Kennedy est tout nouveau président
qu'on lui présente un projet qui est
tout prêt au fond il qu'à l'appliquer il
est ficelé il est clé oui tout à fait il
pourrait dire non il est président des
États-Unis alors ma question c'est
pourquoi il a pas dit non ou il a pas
dit non parce que il a été influencé par
tous par tous ces conseillers et en
particulier par la CIA mais pas
uniquement la CIA il y a aussi la
défense nationale et cetera donc ça veut
dire que en fin de compte il est pris
dans un véritable engrenage et il ne
peut pas refuser il se sent obligé
d'accepter parce que sinon il serait
traître à la cause des États-Unis donc
c'est la raison pour pour laquelle la
baie des Cochons est engagée en avril
2000 en avril
1961 alors pour Castro il y a a il y a
la Révolution Cubaine la prise du
pouvoir en en janvier 59 et puis a la
baie des Cochons ça c'est un véritable
fait d'armes pour Fidel Castro c'est ce
que les Américains les Américains n'ont
pas compris ce qui se passait vraiment à
Cuba parce que Fidel Castro est un génie
de la manipulation et de la manigance
parce qu'il a fait croire longtemps aux
Américains il y a des scènes
extraordinaires d'ailleurs où où il se
fait filmer avec son fils quand il va
aux États-Unis en pyjama pour montrer à
quel point c'est un bon père de famille
et que c'est un gentil garçon et qu'il
aime bien l'Amérique et cetera en fait
il était déjà en train de négocier même
aux mains des des Russes des Soviétiques
depuis longtemps depuis très longtemps
il avait un un un maître un parrain
politique si je puis dire qui était le
le patron de du réseau de renseignement
soviétique pour toute l'Amérique du Sud
qui s'appelait Fabio grobart avec qui on
retrouvera on retrouvera des photos de
Castro avec Fabio grobart des années
plus tard mais c'était un lien quasi
filial qu'il avait avec lui ça les
Américains n'avaient pas tous ces
éléments donc ils avaient l'impression
qu'au fond au début je pense ça va
changer très vite mais au début ils
pensent que finalement c'est un nouveau
Caudillo qui est là qui va qui va faire
comme tous les comme tous les chefs
d'État latino c'est dans un premier
temps ils ont une logoré révolutionnaire
marxisance et cetera et puis après quand
ils sont au pouvoir bah ils deviennent
je dirais pas des des généraux tapioca
mais un peu quand même donc il y avait
cette ID là chez les Américains que de
toute manière il pouvait contrôler Fidel
Castro pourquoi parce que fidè Castro
est un enfant et le fils d'un grand
propriétaire terrien de de la région de
Santiago des Cuba et et tout le monde
était persuadé que de toute manière il
allaiss se rapprocher naturellement des
États-Unis or c'est l'inverse qui s'est
passé à la baie des Cochons il y avait
déjà les agents soviétiques les généraux
soviétiques qui étaient là ils
contrôlaient déjà complètement ils y
avaient déjà de l'armement soviétique
qui était très puissant et Castro avant
la l'intervention américaine avait avait
fait une rafle en particulier dans la
région de l'excambraille pour supprimer
toutes les oppositions 100000 personnes
ont été raflé en quelques jours dans
toute la région justement à côté de PL
akiron la la baie des Cochons donc il y
avait une stratégie cubaine de Fidel
Castro très puissante qui était
incroyablement efficace ce que les
Américains n'ont pas compris ils étaient
encore av visiblement sous-estimé hein
dans cette
la logique c'est la suite finalement et
là le monde a pris peur on a frôé la la
3è guerre mondiale c'est la fameuse
crise des missile cubain nous sommes en
octobre 1962 cette crise cubaine Kennedy
la révèle au grand public le 22 octobre
62 il y aura 7 jours une bonne semaine
de tension extrême où réellement on
craindra une 3ème guerre mondiale avec
la certitude du côté américain que des
rampes de lancement ont été installées
de missilees nucléaaires ont été all du
côté cubain par les Soviétiques et la
fin de l'histoire c'est à nouveau un
historien qui intervient dans ce
documentaire qui nous la raconte en
échangeant le retrait des fusé contre
l'engagement de ne jamais intervenir à
Cuba Kennedy imposait à ses militaires
et à son électorat le respect de la
Révolution Cubaine en habillant cette
retraite diplomatique de l'amour de la
paix et du panage de l'intimidation il a
bien fallu trouver un accord mais cet
accord il a été trouvé avec kutchev ou
avec Castro concernant cette fameuse
affaire d'émicile cubain Castro
n'intervient guerre dans cette affaire
et au fond il l'a beaucoup regretté
ouais on y reviendra d'ailleurs c'est
essentiellement avec kchov que la
négociation s'est faite et en
particulier une sorte d'échange
c'est-à-dire que on les Soviétiques
arrêtent de de de transporter leur fusé
jusqu'à Cuba ils s'arrêtent à un certain
certain nombre de miles et d'autre part
les États-Unis acceptent mais de manière
discrète de retirer leur propre fusée de
Turquie c'est-à-dire qu'au fond krutchov
a dit à Kennedy bon bah c'est très bien
nous allons nous comprenons que Cuba est
à 150 km des côtes de Floride nous
retirons nos nos fusées nous ne les
installerons pas mais en revanche vous
vous avez installé des fusées en Turquie
il faudrait quand même que vous les
retiriez alors ça s'est fait
discrètement mais ce qu'il faut
remarquer quand même c'est que au
lendemain de la des cochons John
Fitgerald Kennedy est très affaibli
quand il vient à Paris dans les jours
qui suivent il était invité par le
général de Gaulle il il représente une
sorte de de jeune président qui n'a pas
su prendre en compte les dimensions de
la stratégie des États-Unis mais une
année plus tard les choses ont changé
c'est-à-dire que Kennedy a pu négocier
avec rutchov à Vienne en juin
1961 il a il a montré en somme par
différents aspects qu'il pouvait être un
président
important un président puissant un
président réfléchi et non pas simplement
une sorte de de jeune de jeune homme
parce que donc on en est déjà plus he au
au John filgerald Kennedy de la baie des
Cochons là hein il a pris la dimension
du il il est tout à fait il est
différent et et en même temps il a la
responsabilité du monde libre il
considère qu'il est le responsable du
monde le champion du monde libre et
qu'en conséquence s'il ne trouve pas un
accord avec rutchov ça signifie que la
planète toute entière risque de sauter
c'est-à-dire qu'au fond les deux
puissances nucléaires pourraient
s'affronter et ça serait évidemment une
catastrophe mondiale donc personne ne
pourrait se relever alors c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut négocier
mais il faut négocier dans le secret il
faut négocier enensme pour éviter qu'il
y ait des fuites et c'est qui explique
que pendant une huuitaine de jours la
négociation se poursuit sans que les
Américains soient véritablement au
courant de ce que fait leur président
ouais et vous disiez que ça a été fait
dans le plus grand secret euh le retrait
des missiles américains en Turquie qui
faisait partie bien entendu de l'OTAN a
été officiellement divulgué 25 ans ah
oui après c'est cette fameuse cette
fameuse affaire j'en profite pour vous
montrer une carte vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure voilà euh cette carte la
situation de Cuba vis-à-vis des
États-Unis et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure he 150 km c'est par la pointe de
la Floride que nous voyons sur cette
carte avec avec Cuba hein et donc on
comprend toute la dangerosité hein
d'avoir des missiles pointés sur les
États-Unis à cette époque cette crise de
Cuba essentiellement négociée du côté
américain avec krutchev et ça Castro a
eu du mal visiblement à à avaler la
couleuf parce que lui aussi voulait
participer à cette négociation il en
aura voulu semble-t-il à crou chef de ne
pas avoir été impliqué dans cette
négociation à l'occasion de cette crise
c'est vrai et bien sûr il a même tout
tout fait pour mettre des battons dans
les roues dans dans dans cette
négociation en particulier pour le
départ des Soviétiques et cetera ça a
été très compliqué mais quand on reprend
le fil de l'histoire c'est
extraordinaire c'està-dire qu'en fait
c'est une opération soviétique euh il y
a une anecdote qui est intéressante
c'est Raoul Castro qui va est invité le
frère de de fidèle qui est invité à
Moscou il sait pas encore très bien
pourquoi il est reçu par gromico à
l'époque le patron des des Affaires
étrangères de de l'Union soviétique et
ils sont là en train de picoler un peu
ils boitent de la vodka et cetera ils
savent que Raoul Castro aime bien lever
le verre et et et ils lui font signer un
papier lui voilà il faut que tu signes
ce papier c'est un papier justement qui
est un accord de Cuba pour que les
Russes viennent installer des missiles à
ogive nucléaire donc lui il est un peu
surpris parce que tout d'un coup c'est
l'apocal doit signer l'Apocalypse
l'Apocalypse oui donc il est il était
pas du tout au courant de ce qui est en
train de se passer donc les Russes en
fait vont organiser cette opération
pratiquement au nez et à la barbe de
Castro il faut savoir par exemple que
les bases militaires soviétiques sur
Cuba quand elles sont installées les
Cubains n'ont pratiquement pas le droit
d'y aller à part Castro qui a imposé de
pouvoir y aller une fois c'est une
opération soviétique complètement pour
une raison très simple on n'est pas très
loin de l'affaire du mur de Berlin le
mur de Berlin HRI caspi pourra me
reprendre c'était il y a 2 seulement en
61 voilà exactement donc
l'ilo capitaliste au cœur de l'Empire
socialiste communiste existe à Berlin
Ouest et krutchev lui qu'est-ce qu'il
veut il veut lui aussi avoir son îlo
communiste au cœur du monde capitaliste
évidemment les États-Unis veulent
absolument pas de ça donc il y a cette
affaire qui n'est uniquement une affaire
diplomatique que Castro ne comprend pas
puisque même à un moment donné ils sont
prêts eux à faire la guerre on sait
qu'il y a cette fameuse scne où
cheegevara dit qu'il faut détruire New
York il faut détruire Chicago et cetera
donc il y a vraiment une volonté de
martyrologue de la part de de de de je
parle de des de l'entourage de fidèle
Castro qui va être mise en brèche mais
pendant longtemps Castro va faire la
tête aux Russes il a fallu que un an
plus tard krutchev l'invite pendant un
mois en visite d'État pour justement le
caliner pour lui dire qu'au contraire il
reste au cœur du jeu et cetera un mois
il a eu droit à tous les égards toutes
les médailles que l'Union soviétique
peut peut décerner à la terre entière
Castro était couvert de médailles
soviétique et donc son orgueil était si
je puis dire rasséréné et les relations
ont pu reprendre normalement mais ce que
dit Serge Raffi était extrêmement
intéressant parce que cela montre au
fond que l'attitude soviétique à
l'encontre de Cuba est encore pire que
l'attitude américaine à l'encontre de
Cuba c'està-dire qu'au fond les Cubains
ont intérêt peut-être à jouer sur les
deux superpuissances mais d'un autre
côté il est évident que ça n'est pas du
côté soviétique qu'ils vont avoir une
dose de sympathie d'amitié débordante
l'Union soviétique défend ses intérêts
et il se méfie de Castro depuis le début
et non seulement l'Union soviétique
défend ses intérêts mais ne tient aucun
compte des intérêts de Fidel Castro je
le répète parce que quand même Cuba est
tout proche des États-Unis et cela
voudrait dire que de la part de l'Union
soviétique il y ait un minimum de
réflexion vis-à-vis de cette attitude
nécessaire indispensable que les Cubains
doivent avoir à l'encontre des
États-Unis et puis arrive ce fameux 22
novembre
1963 le jour de l'assassinat du
président Kennedy à Dallas Texas bien
sûr jeandiel est au côté de de fidèle
Castro et c'est en direct que c
l'annonce de cet assassinat extrait du
documentaire le commandant Val a capé
l'mission en anglais de LABC à
Miami trad les nouvelles à
FID blessure à la
tête fuite de
l'assassin meurtre d'un
policier enfin l'annonce
fatale le président Kennedy est
mort fidèle se lève et
dit voilà c'est la fin de votre mission
de paix voilà c'est la fin de votre
mission de paix voilà ce qu'aurait dit
Castro à jean-diel et jeandiel la
confirm bien sûr par la suite est-ce
qu'à ce moment précis contte tenu des
confidences qu'avait fait Castro à
jean-del dans les heures
précédente Castro était prêt à une
ouverture à mettre en place une
négociation secrète ou officielle avec
les États-Unis avant cette annonce c'est
pas impossible parce que l'économie
cubaine est si je peux dire à la ramasse
complète c'est une catastrophe la
dernière Safra la fameuse récolte de
canne à sucre c'est la pire de tous les
temps de Cuba c'est-à-dire que le le
volontarisme cubain tout tous les
discours grandiloquant de la de la
nomenclature cubaine sont totalement
totalement inefficient c'est une
catastrophe le pays se se dirige
directement vers la misère il se sort
rendu compte d'abord qu'il n'avait pas
les compétences pour pour gérer un pays
qui n'avait pas les techniciens puisque
beaucoup sont partis et beaucoup de
techniciens américains sont partis il
faut rappeler qu'avant 59 le Cuba était
un un des pays les plus prospères
d'Amérique latine on peut parler des
casinos de la prostitution c'est vrai
mais aussi c'est un pays très prospère
ils avaient déjà en 58 la télévision les
Cubains c'est-à-dire que c'était pas du
tout un pays pauvre et cetera c'était
pas un pays tir on disait du tout mais
en quelques années la la comment je
dirais la jeunte castrce puisque c'est
devenu très très vite une dictature
militaire en a fait un pays pauvre un
pays de mendiant où pour pouvoir se
nourrir il fallait aller chercher le
fameux carnet qu'on appelait la libreta
qui est un carnet de rationnement où en
fait vous avez droit à trois œufs un
litre de lait et cetera tout ça est allé
très très vite donc autrement dit dans
l'esprit Castro peut-être il a BES
s'agissait de s'appuyer à la fois bien
sûr sur l'Union soviétique pour les
raisons qu'on a évoqué mais aussi de
renouveler un dialogue avec les
États-Unis petite anecdote il faut
savoir que je vais très vite la
nouvelle-orléand c'était le port cubain
en fait parce qu'il avait un tonnage
tellement grand qu'il pouvait
effectivement hors à Cuba le port de
Mariel par exemple n'a pas le même
tonnage que la nouvelle-orléand donc il
ne pouvait pas emmener des bateaux même
avec les Américains donc il fallait
trouver des nouvelles portes et il ne
pouvait pas se passer économiquement des
Américains alors Fidel Castro une autre
phrase qu'il prononce à jean-diel dans
des heures sombres il vous allez voir on
va mettre ça sur le dos oui cet
assassinat oui ça a été le cas oui entre
autres c'est-à-dire qu'au fond
aujourd'hui les hypothèses sont
multiples sur les raisons de
l'assassinat de Kennedy il y a eu en
effet une hypothèse qui consistait à
dire que c'était par vengeance que les
Cubains de Fidel Castro avaient projeté
et réalisé l'assassinat de Kennedy rien
ça rien ne le prouve rien ne le prouve
parce que si on prend le simplement de
lar veroswald qui est en principe
l'assassin seul et unique de Kennedy je
dis en principe parce que je n'ai pas de
connaissance
particulière jetiens la verion
officielle bon si on prend le cas de lar
voswald il est à la fois proche des
milieux cubains et des milieux
antiubains c'est-à-dire qu'au fond on
sait pas très bien ce qu'il agite donc
il est vraisemblable que les
cubainsoswalt est membre d'une
association d'un mouvement pro castriste
il en est le seul membre par exemple
hein pour illustrer ce que vous non et
et puis il faut également mentionner que
laroswald a des liens ou avait des liens
avec l'Union soviétique mais tout cela
explique enensble aussi avec la CIA
pardon mais aussi avec la CIA oui bien
sûr il avait des liens avec tout le
monde ouais c'estàdire qu'au fond on
sait pas très bien si c'est un agent ou
un contreagent on ne sait pas très bien
fa d'ailleurs si on on va si on
s'intéresse de près à la trajectoire de
de l'ARV Oswald c'est absolument inoui
puisque il rentre dans les Marines très
très jeuneou il part dans une base
navale au Japon qui est complètement
contrôlé par la CIA il est technicien
radar là-bas il y reste pratiquement un
an il rentre aux États-Unis à la base
navale del Toro pour pour partir pas
vers l'Union soviétique ça c'est après
mais d'abord cette base navale del Toro
est complètement contrôlé par la CIA
c'est là où il va rencontrer ces fameux
agents qu'on va retrouver dans
l'assassinat qui s'appelle app Sturgis
emings et cetera qui étaient des agents
qui sont devenus qui étaient d'ailleurs
l'un était même dans la Sierra Maestra
c'est-à-dire qu'il a été berné lui-même
par Castro qui a cru c'est très
compliqué donc HERV Oswald après vous
avez raison après ce passage CIA à El
torau en Californie tout d'un coup il
s'en va il part par la fin pous Mar et
il demande il demande un statut de de de
réfugier politique donc là on rentre
dans une affaire d'espionnage
extraordinaire oswal ce n'est pas simple
une chèvre qui arrive comme ça dans dans
un
immeuble je vous donnerai la parole
juste après Seri le fait est que du côté
américain on a
sérieusement regardé du côté de cette
piste oui bien sr soit castriste soit
anticastriste d'aç a un lien entre eux
les deux sont possibles de même que on
s'est demandé du côté américain si ça
n'était pas les services secrets des
États-Unis qui avaient manigancé cette
cet assassinat parce qu'ils étaient
contre le rapprochement entre Washington
et La Havane on s'est demandé aussi si
c'était pas les milieux d'affaires
américains surtout les milieux
d'affaires un peu trouble hein parce que
les les affaires avec Cuba n'étaient pas
non plus tout à fait
régulières la mafia était très présente
la mafia aurait perdu 1 milliard de
dollars hm hm après la Révolution
Cubaine oui hein donc ça ça ça illustre
assez bien l'ampleur des intérêts ne
serait-ce que de la mafia oui mais tout
tout cela en somme tout cela en somme
repose sur un certain nombre
d'hypothèses il y a eu plusieurs
commission d'enquête ces commissions
d'enquête ont finalement abouti à la
conclusion que pour l'instant pour le
moment contenu des des preuves dont on
disposait bon ben pour le moment Lee
harvé Oswald est le seul qui est
assassiné Kennedy c'est-à-dire qu'au
fond il fait pas partie d'un complot
alors est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que
c'est pas vrai personne ellement je n'en
sais rien je vous avoue franchement que
je n'étais pas présent à Dallas en
1963 et qu'aujourd'hui encore je reste
dans l'incertitude parce que bon
j'accepte la version officielle ouais
alors il y a eu deux commissions
d'enquête à propos de cet assassinat aux
États-Unis la commission d'enquête
Warren qui a rendu d'ailleurs son son
rapport en 1964 moins d'un an après en
réalité cet assassinat et puis celle de
stroke je précise que waren était quand
même le le président de la Cour suprême
oui tout à fait pas n'importe qui ouais
euh et puis la commission tox qui elle
travaill entre 76 et 79 autrement dit 13
ans et rend son rapport 16 ans après ce
fameux assassinat il conclut tous les
deux que larve Oswald aurait participé à
ce à cet assassinat avec trois trois
coups de feu mais la différence c'est
qu'effectivement dans la commission
stoks il est question d'un 4è coup de
feu hein ce scénario est envisagé qui
aurait été tiré par un autre que Oswald
et à ce moment-là qui dit deux tireurs
dit complot par rapport à la rencontre
de jean-diel oui bien sûr et de et de et
de Fidel Castro donc c'està-dire le une
recherche de la paix si on peut dire
négociation il faut savoir que pendant
un an après l'affaire des des missile et
bien JFK va faire un certain nombre de
signes de va lancer des signaux à Castro
pour lui prouver sa bonne volonté en
particulier il ferme des camps de
d'entraînement de de d'anticastriste
dans les Everglades et puis ensuite le
dernier à porcharttrin où était
d'ailleurs l'arvé Oswald dans ce camp il
participait aux entraînements pour
assassiner Castro c'est-à-dire qu'on est
dans une espèce de folie et là donc
Kennedy il dit il dit on arrête tout ça
on veut plus cette folie on arrête et je
pense qu'effectivement beaucoup de gens
et même dans la CIA qui se préparaient
depuis des années quand même depuis des
années depuis les années début 60 à
organisé l'assassinat de Fidel Castro se
retrouve dans une position et donc
l'idée que JFK a pu courousser si je
puis dire toute une partie des anti des
anticastristes qui qui étaient à Miami
ou ailleurs aux États-Unis a joué
certainement un rôle très important et
la CIA participait à cette opération
permettez je voudrais ajouter deux
points le le premier tout d'abord c'est
que Lee Harve hoswald a été assassiné
dans les 48 heures c'est la raison une
des raisons pour lesquelles on ne
connaît pas vraiment ses motivations au
moment où il participe sans doute à
l'assassinat Kennedy et il a été
assassiné par Jack Ruby qui lui-même a
été condamné à mort et qui est mort dans
sa prison de maladie en 1967 ce qui veut
dire au fond que les traces concernant
l'assassinat sont particulièrement
vagues et puis d'autre part je crois
qu'il faut souligner que en
1963 l'intérêt majeur de Kennedy ça
n'est plus Cuba c'est de plus en plus le
Vietnam c'est-à-dire qu'au fond on
change de perspective autant en 1961
Cuba était au centre des préoccupations
des États-Unis parce que Cuba c'était la
porte à côté autant en
1963 l'engagement au Vietnam devient de
plus en plus pressant et et va déboucher
avec le successeur de Kennedy c'estàd
Lindon Johnson par une avec dans
l'implication massive des troupes
américaines au Vietnam donc ça veut dire
au fond que le Cuba n'est plus au centre
Cuba est un peu est à l'extérieur
désormais et on peut continuer à faire
des affaires avec Cuba on peut continuer
à gérer la base de Guantanamo on peut
laisser la mafia agir comme elle a envie
de le faire du côté de La Havane si elle
y arrive mais ça n'est plus en somme la
préoccupation essentielle des Américains
alors le fait est de constater que il
aura fallu beaucoup d'années hein après
euh cet assassinat du JFK pour voir les
deux pays en arriver à un rétablissement
des relations diplomatiques et ce
rétablissement il arrive le 1er juillet
entre Raoul Castro frère de fidè Castro
et Obama qui est alors le président des
États-Unis quelle longue parenthèse pour
enfin avoir un dialogue des relations
diplomatiques dignes de ce nom officiel
misise en place il avait raison
peut-être Fidel
Castro c'estàd que le le régime était à
bout de souffle je parlais de de ce qui
s'était passé dès les années 60 ça ne
s'est pas arrangé l'Union soviétique a
disparu hein l'Union soviétique a
disparu on n plus dans les mêmes
rapports de force mais ce qui est
certain aussi c'est que Raoul Castro ce
n'est pas fidèle Castro c'est à une
personnalité très différente beaucoup
plus pragmatique même si lui il a été
vraiment entre les mains de de l'Union
soviétique il a été vraiment un militant
marxiste ce qu'il a fait dans la Sira
des cristals pendant la pendant la la
Révolution et pendant la la Guera
c'était il a il a installé lui des des
colcauses il a privatisé il a pardon il
a nationalisé le maximum il est vraiment
l'idéologue du communisme cubain Raoul
Castro et l'homme des Russes mais donc
quand il arrive en 2015 effectivement
l'affaire le pays est toujours au au
même point et effectivement il y a
longtemps d'ailleurs que les Russes sont
partis les Russes partent au début des
années 90 et l'économie cubaine va de
mal en pis donc il a absolument besoin
de retrouver des des relations prudentes
hein c'est pas non plus pardon existe
toujours n'oublieze la Paro soviétique a
disparu mais krutchov lui-même en 1964
est écarté du pouvoir c'est-à-dire qu'au
fond en
1964 les principaux acteurs outre fidèle
cast ne sont plus là tout à fait ouais
ouis Obama c'est lui qui renoue les
relations avec ce pays oui Obama vous
savez a fait beaucoup de choses he mais
cela dit un démocrate comme Kennedy il
fallait que ça soit un démocrate pour le
faire peut-être oui peut-être non il
s'agissait simplement de savoir si
c'était dans l'intérêt des États-Unis ce
n'est pas la préoccupation essentielle
des États-Unis pour Obama la
préoccupation essentielle sur le plan
extérieur c'est éventuellement les
relations avec l'Iran éventuellement les
relations avec les autres puissances du
Moyen-Orient ou en Afrique mais le Cuba
ça n'est pas vraiment primordial dans
les préoccupations d'Obama simplement
c'est c'est une manière au fond de de
fermer la parenthèse N un problème
international c'est devenu un problème
national c'està dire c'est un problème
interne aux États-Unis
parunigr cubains qui arrivent la
communauté cubaine tous les exilés
cubains qui se sont s'inallés soit après
l'affaire Mariel après tout un tas de il
y avait l'affaire des B people aussi il
y en a eu ce qu'on appelait balceros
c'estàdire qui partait sur des sur des
bouées carrément pour rejoindre la
Floride la communauté CUB surtout au
milieu des années 90 absolument la
communauté cubaine aux États-Unis est
très puissante elle a d'ailleurs
énormément de sénateurs de gouverneurs
de de Mair de grande ville et très
puissant en Floride surtout absolument
et mais ça pèse parfois pour les
élections présidentielles donc c'est
devenu vraiment et et les les Américains
le vivent comme un problème interne Cuba
n'est plus un problème il vous reste 20
secondes chacun 20 secondes chacun
rendez-vous manqué point d'interrogation
GfK Castro
oui et non je dirais que pour JFK
c'était pas le problème essentiel en en
novembre 1963 ça l'était certainement en
1961 ça ne l'est plus en 1963 bon voilà
sergeapi je pense que dire que c'est
raté ou pas le problème avec avec fidè
Castro c'est que on ne sait jamais
vraiment ce qu'il va faire après
c'est-à-dire est-ce que cette maintendue
de JFK aurait servi à quelque chose ou
pas ça l'histoire ne nous le dira pas
ouis et on le saura jamais non
simplement ce qu'on peut noter c'est que
Fidel Castro meurt après cette
réconciliation entre son frère et Barak
obaba ironie de l'histoire il mourra le
25 novembre 2016 à l'âge de 90 ans
fidèle Castro un grand merci vraiment à
tous les deux he d'avoir participé à
cette émission desbadoc aujourd'hui
après ce ce documentaire que nous
proposions aujourd'hui dans cette
émission vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag desbadg merci à sel Mali qui m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission je vous
retrouve même place même heure et ça
sera bien sûr un débat doc avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]